so welcome everybody to my talk about
uncertainty quantification in AI before
is that a few words about myself I'm a
principal data scientist at innovates
innovation IT project house medium-sized
like we are 350 employees and being a
mathematician my like main activities
are mathematical modeling so somehow
translating practical use cases into the
language of mathematics to then
eventually solve them I'm also big fan
of like putting things really to
production so not just stopping at some
proof of concept but really showing the
value of machine learning of data
science by putting by deploying it and
gaining then more revenue or some things
also other like special interests I have
I really like everything about
recommender system which is a hot topic
nowadays also uncertainty quantification
of course this is why I'm here lately
also causality because I think those two
points and thirdly quantification
causality will be and become much more
important in the future I'm also a fan
of the patent data stack of course
that's why I'm here and I'm a maintainer
of a little project of my own PI
scaffold so if you ever want to like set
up your own project in a standardized
way to package your project to ship it
then please have a look at PI scaffold
so the work I'm going to present today
it's actually that my work but it's the
work of one of my students so he mainly
did all of it and he was supervising him
in a master thesis now he's an esteemed
colleague of mine and he's also written
a really cool blog post about this and
if you want to get even more more
details you can even download his master
thesis so he's a mathematician a little
bit shy this is why he's not here I am I
just like to go to conferences so this
is the ground we gonna cover today first
gonna start with the motivation so why
should you actually care about
uncertainty quantification what is all
about and why it's important then I'm
going to present
different methods different we were
gonna stop it something like really
mathy like Gaussian processes if you
have been to some of the other talks
yesterday you heard already a lot about
Gaussian processes so we're gonna use
this as a baseline then compared to for
other methods which are more based on
deep learning approaches we're gonna
evaluate those five methods together in
some experiments to show the pros and
cons of each of those methods and some
quantitative qualitative rule of thumb
went to apply which and of course in the
end some short wrap-up and conclusion so
let's start with the motivation so you
surely all know those nice deep learning
classification neural networks where you
put in some some image and then you end
up with the classification if it's a cat
a dog a hot dog or whatever and you
might wonder actually so yeah the guys
talking about uncertainty quantification
as if it's something new but actually
already here in those networks we have
some probabilities right we have the
softmax layers we get as probabilities
and in case of this cat it's 90% so it
seems to work if we put in another
picture maybe of this dog the network is
a little bit less certain about it but
what actually happens if we put
something completely different in there
some kind of image we have never trained
on some computer with some complete new
class like a bird so in this case you
might assume that the network will tell
you something like 50% the dog 50% a cat
in a way telling you I have never seen
anything like this before but actually
what might happen that you end up having
70% cat or 80% dog so it's not it's not
guaranteed what kind of what kind of
results you're gonna get so you could
get anything because there was never
imaged only like similar to this in your
training set and the network has no way
of telling you I'm completely answered
about the outcome so please don't rely
on my on my outcome on my prediction and
I mean it's all fun and games if we're
talking only about classification of
cats and dogs but you might think that
if you do at anonymous driving and if
you have a classification like this for
traffic signs then it becomes really
important that if you put in some
pictures that are not a traffic sign
that somehow your your classification
model has a way of telling you so I'm
not I'm not certain what it is and just
doesn't give you just some random answer
and so why is this so why doesn't it
work so beginning of the year I heard a
really cool talk about the intuition
about this at the triple AI the paper is
called learning and the unknown and in
this case it's lore there was given an
example of four different classes like
those four colors and what does a deep
neural network do I mean a deep neural
network we've all learned that you kind
of it helps you do the feature
engineering it it's fine some some
internal latent space but in the end the
neural network deep neural network does
something really simple in this internal
representation that is shown here it
still finds those decision boundaries
like your the circles would be the
training examples and we have this
decision boundaries and within this
decision boundaries it will give you a
high certainty about an instance being
in this class if it's far away from this
decision boundary so this is all fine if
you end up with the instance you want to
predict somewhere around here but in
case like with our bird what happens
we somewhere ended up completely far
ways which is zoomed out in the right
picture and we ended up somewhere in
this open space and due to the fact how
a neural network is constructed in case
of a classification those decision
boundaries go up until infinity so if
you land
somewhere in this open space there's
some new instance you might get a really
high certainty that you are in the green
class for instance but actually you're
not you're just somewhere completely
different and so this is for for
classification problem but still you
have those those probabilities in case
of this softmax but it's actually even
worse if we look at another problem if
you look at regression problems for
instance here I we made a simple 1d
function we generated some some
observations those are the crosses and
we let a neural network learn the the
interpolation of this of this data
points and you see that the the fit it
looks quite well right so it which shows
mean squared error to to minimize we
will end up having a kind of mean but
already looking at this you see that we
only for each point we get only a single
function value right so the deep
learning network it just has one output
so we have no notion of the fact that
somehow there seems to be noise in our
data right so here so two or three or
four points which are really close in
its its point they are quite different
in the function value so the network is
not showing us this uncertainty it's
just giving us a single point and we're
gonna here in the next presentation for
instance that if you want to do some
optimization with the results you're
gonna need the whole distribution and
not only a single data point so this is
the interpolation case so we had data
from zero to ten but now what happens if
we look beyond this interval so again
like in the classification problem what
happens if we look beyond our data
points so what the network does is it
just gives us some results and due to
the fact that we chose the the de Loup
activation function
you know the de l'eau is Lin
for positive numbers so this network
will come up with any kind of linear
function beyond the point 10 and below
zero if we compare this to the actual
true function then of course it's
completely different I mean how would it
know otherwise how can it know but again
the main point is the network did not
tell us that it's completely unsure and
in the in the interval it's worked quite
well but outside you just end up with
random number and this is something you
don't want to have in a production
system for instance because if this was
multi-dimensional you could not as
clearly see that you are now in a region
where you had no data points right so
what we rather would like to have is a
network that gives us something like
this like confidence intervals like
those shaded areas are 0.5 Sigma
standard deviations in each direction
and that we could get something like
this because then we would see ok here
between 0 to 10 there is this is the
mean but we have some some random noise
in the data and this is some some these
are the confidences we have about our
prediction and if we go outside this
region we see ok we are getting more and
more uncertain as we move away from our
trainings data so now implicitly we've
already talked about two kinds of
uncertainty and I want to define those
so first of all this intrinsic noise is
called Ally Ettrick nose so this is the
noise due to the fact how you might
measure the data maybe you have some
measurement errors maybe you also just
don't have each covariate for instance
so let's assume you're shooting an arrow
and you have all the data about your
angle the thrust how far your target is
away and so on you have all the data
that you could physically like like use
Newton or whatever to
to calculate where the arrow is going to
hit the target but if you do the same if
you shoot the same way twice you will
still have little noise because due to
the let's say wind or whatever different
pressure in the air and if this is if
this is something you cannot measure
then you will have some kind of
intrinsic noise and this is the aleatory
noise and the most important thing to
remember about the aleatory noise if we
collect more of the same data then we
will not be able to to decrease aleatory
noise in contrast to that we have the
so-called epistemic noise so this is
noise to to the fact that we lack
certain knowledge that will act data
that we lack knowledge about the
underlying process and this is something
we can of course improve if we gather
more data and in some uses cases you
could imagine it makes even sense to be
able to to split your uncertainty into
an eletric part into an epistemic part
because if the aleatory kiff you only
have electric noise and you know the the
noise is still too big for your use case
the uncertainty is too high then you
might try and look again maybe you need
more coverage covariates you're missing
some features whatever or let's say the
other way around you have a lot of
epistemic noise then of course you would
just try and gather more data at these
points so now let's let's talk about the
method so what can be used to actually
accomplish this we're gonna start with
the baseline the gaussian processes
they're like really mathematical and
then as we go on we're gonna relax on
different mathematical assumptions we're
gonna ignore distributions and so on as
we go away and the methods itself become
I would say more and more heuristic
especially with the Monte Carlo drops a
lot drop outs but let's first start off
with something more mathematical with
the Gaussian processes so I'm gonna give
you only like a release
more like intuition what the Gaussian
process is maybe or raise your hand who
knows what a Gaussian process is already
ok so quite a lot so to to give a
repetition so a Gaussian process is a
kind of distribution and if you would
normally think of some some random
variable if you pull one sound perform a
random variable you end up having a
number or vector or whatever but if you
ask for example from a Gaussian of a
Gaussian process you end up having a
whole function so this is the is that
the difference and a function so what's
really fascinating is I mean a function
has a kind of infinite number of points
right so you have a lot of points and a
lot of function values so how would this
the Gaussian process accomplish this
that it gives you back a whole function
so actually you're never practically
dealing with infinite number of points
right so for a function for us it's
enough to have a finite number of points
a finite number of fanged function
values and there comes now the relation
of a Gaussian process to a normal
distribution in because if you ask the
Gaussian process for the the for a
finite number of points then it will
give you back a normal distribution and
then yeah we are back at something we
know
so the normal distribution in a
multi-dimensional case has a mean vector
and the covariance matrix and since we
could ask the Gaussian process for any
kind of points we have to kind of
generate those vectors and this matrix
for all kinds of points so this is why
we have functions here so it's a kind of
I see there's a kind of generalization
of the normal distribution and so as I
said we have instead of a mean vector we
have a mean function and covariance
function which gives us then some
covariance matrix given some points and
the the things we kind of put in there
in this Gaussian process if we set
something up like like the prior
information is for
instance if we are looking for functions
that have a certain trend or if we are
looking for functions that are really
smooth so if we want to express the
notion that if two points when they are
close together the function values
should really highly likely be also
close together then this is something we
can encode into the covariance function
but a picture says more than a thousand
births so it's actually clear if we look
at some examples let's take this
exponential covariance function and you
can see that this would generate really
smooth function because if this is
really close then the covariance between
two points is really really high and if
we now take just the zero function for
the mean and this is how a Gaussian
process would would would look like the
distributions so again we have we have
for the shadings we have two like yeah
like a visualization of the distribution
and those colored lines are just random
samples from this distribution and the
dashed line is is the mean if we somehow
know that we are rather looking for
functions with trend then this would be
we could for instance choose this mean
function and have a distribution that
looks like this so far I've only talked
about like how to how to come up with
Gaussian process how to construct it how
to put up the your a knowledge into it
so far we have not seen any data so you
might wonder how that's now inference
works so let's assume I have some data
points what happens now so again this is
like if we have no data at all so it's
the prior let's assume we get three
different data points here there and
there and now we can like due to the
fact that we are dealing internally with
a lot of normal distribution
and they have a lot of nice property so
we can just condition on those points
and calculate posterior and then our
distribution looks like this so the
resulting posterior so in this case just
for illustration I choose perfect
interpolation so we see that now the
mean function just yeah interpolates
those those given data points we also
see to the fact of the covariance
function that if we go in the middle
between two points then the the
uncertainty is quite high and as we go
closer to one of the points that
uncertainty becomes small and again the
colored lines are just now random some
samples this also works of course with
noisy observations I mean this is
something how we do how we would do it
in in in practice and there we see then
that there still uncertainty even we if
we have a point here and there and for
instance here we had like put four
points yeah four data points at eight so
you see that the uncertainty is smaller
than for instance here so just to show
you a little formula how this looks like
so the axis would be your data the data
we are having and X star would be the
data points we want to evaluate the
function so this is kind of where we
want to do our predictions and the only
important thing to actually notice here
are those two terms because because they
are really computationally intensive so
if you remember maybe your your computer
science classes or whatever if you have
to invert a matrix this has cubic
complexity and if this covariance matrix
is as big as your as the number of data
points you have then it is completely
unfeasible if you are doing anything
related to big data so there are
different ways how to get around it but
this is seen as like the major drop
of course and processes because yeah for
small data problems to actually work
really really well and if I kind of yeah
get your interest on this if you want to
read more about Gaussian processes then
there's really cool tutorials of
Christopher phones back some really nice
talks about it and how you can do this
with pi MC which is a really cool
library by the way so this Gaussian
process as I said we're gonna use this
layer as a kind of baseline a
mathematical baseline to compare the
other methods to and now to the first
like deep learning based approach how to
get uncertainty quantification you all
might know the drop out technique right
drop out is a way that is used in most
modern machine deep learning models to
regularize your your network so it works
by randomly activating and deactivating
certain notes during the training time
and this like intuitively like spreads
the information more over the whole
network instead of being just local and
yeah helps to generalize during training
time and the idea of this paper was of
2016 I CML was okay what if we don't
just use this during training time what
if we also use this during prediction
time meaning what happens if we if we do
a prediction with a new value here we
also randomly activate and deactivate
the internal nodes and run this a
hundred times and then we'll get a
hundred different outputs and of these
hundred different outputs we can do just
things like calculating a mean
calculating standard deviation to give
us an uncertainty right and the idea is
if the network is quite sure then having
dropout doing prediction should give us
an almost the same values while if it's
really unsure then it should good of
should give us a right spread of values
so this is the basic idea already of
Montecarlo dropout so if you train this
you have to be a little bit careful if
you also do weight decay because this
this probability of making a drop out
will play a role in this formula but all
the details are also in the in the
master Theseus so this was like the
first approach another approach is how
you can achieve uncertainty
quantification it's called deep
ensembles it's from a nips paper of 2017
here the basic idea is what if we don't
take a neural network that has only a
single output like normally but what if
we would try to canary the whole
distribution and how do you get a
distribution you fit the parameters of a
distribution like in a case of a normal
distribution the mean and the variance
and then of course in practice you're
gonna ask yourself okay I got a single
value as a target point how would I now
kind of fit the standard deviation I
mean this is something I don't have my
data but it turns out if you just look
at negative log likelihood of your
normal distribution you can just use a
custom loss function so you would not
just you know use a mean squared error
but you can use this to actually fit it
and what we see here we get some mean
squared error here and we kind of if the
network says that standard deviation is
the variance is really high then this
becomes low but on the other hand this
term then becomes high so you got this
both terms kind of fighting each other
and this is how it eventually finds good
parameters for normal distribution and
fits it so this already sounds good like
okay we have a way to fit the
distribution so we get some uncertainty
but it turns out that the variance is
quite high if you do it like this first
of all you have to be careful how you
drain so you cannot regular rice with
drop out you can do with something like
that the adversarial training like
finding you data points that are really
close to your original data points doing
pseudo data points and so on but still
you will get a high variance
independence of your initial
initialization of your weights so this
is where the the ensemble part comes in
so what the paper suggested is that you
do this now like really yeah with many
many networks let's say five to ten or
twenty networks you train them and you
get a lot of different parameters for
your normal distribution and then you
just average them again so this is the
basic idea this is where the a sample
comes in of course then you decrease
your your variance again in your
estimation of this and as you already
see if I got to Train many networks then
this becomes computationally really
intense and this is why C Mon so the
master student came up with a cool idea
so what if we now combine the two
methods the Monte Carlo and the deep
ensemble method and just call it dropout
ensembles basically taking a single
network of the deep ensembles but
instead of having that multiple times
what if we just think of each instance
in this example is just another dropout
configuration and by this we will also
get different means and different
variances and we can do the calculation
of those central means and central stab
with standard deviations again so this
was kind of way about what he came up in
his math ascesis as an additional
beneficial suggestion so as the really
last method I'm going to show really
easy one so quantile regression which
can also be done with the help of neural
networks and it's a really simple method
but yeah works surprisingly well so
again to explain what this method does
what is again a cumulative distribution
function I've given here the definition
see a kind of given some point you're
kind of looking for the probability
towel that they're showing our points in
your random distribution that are below
or equal point and the quant is actually
just the inverse function so given some
some tau some probability you try to
find that point Y so that this equation
is fulfilled and you might wonder okay
so how if we're given that if I want to
find the quantile function and I mean if
you have the quantile of course you
could perfectly measure and quantize
your uncertainty because you know
everything about distribution if you
choose different house and you might
wonder okay how can I use now some just
neural network to actually fit this
values and this is quite easy as it
turns out so you just take custom loss
function and what's special about a loss
function that it makes a difference
between kind of right arrow and the left
arrow so if my estimation of the
quantile is below the actual value or
above the actual value and then another
distinguishing point is that we don't
have like normal sum squared error or
something nonlinear so we have at least
like something piecewise linear here we
just take the absolute value and then we
do some weightings between those left
and right arrows so for me actually to
be honest when I first saw it it was
kind of okay this really works and I'm
going to show you in some simple example
that it's actually really easy so if we
if we take for instance the median so
0.5 then tau would be 0.5 here and here
so we can just ignore it for moments so
how this would
looked like now in 1d let's assume we
have four points at 0.1 0.2 0.5 and 0.8
and we assume that our median is here
wrongly then we would have those four
arrows yeah so tooth point zero once or
two and so on and since we call this now
kind of right-hand side arrows because
the error is in this one the example on
the right side and the arrow is in total
one point six so the sum back
propagation would maybe tell us okay we
got to move on a little bit higher let's
say we move on to zero point one in this
case we decrease the arrow of four times
we have four data points by our step
with which was zero point one and we end
up have a one point two still not right
so we go on one more point and now we
see that what happens is that from here
to there we decreased by zero point
three but increased now we have now the
the the left left-hand side arrow and we
are basically also done here if we since
we have now an even number of points so
any so according to our minimization
function any point between those two
will do for a median so the interesting
thing and now the actual intuition comes
in if we go on one step further and you
see that between those two slides what
happens as we increase the arrow on the
right hand side by decrease by 0.1 we
directly increase it so this is this
piecewise linear of the of the absolute
value and so we are just trying to find
points to find a point where there is
the same amount of data points on the
left hand side as there is on the right
hand side and now comes in the waiting
so if we would now assume the 75
percentile then we can just accomplished
this by weighting the right hand side
error more than the left-hand-side error
so in our case it would be three times
and that means to get this like tipping
point as we have had before we would
need to jump somewhere in this region
because now as this arrow weights three
times then it's equal to this arrow and
this is the whole intuition why this
quantile regression actually works now
through the experiment to compare those
methods we took a function from from
another from a PhD thesis actually that
someone suggested to evaluate the
function the weekly function that you've
seen before and we generated the data
points with 0.5 standard deviation and
yeah generally different number of
points and let it let it run here again
is our data set with yeah this is 5
Sigma and total confidence interval and
the mean and for all our methods which
are based on on deep learning methods
which shows two hidden layers with 20
raloo neurons 5 networks only for the
deep ensembles because it already took
quite a while to to train for all the
different experiments and their
variations 100 iterations to make in
this drop out the different predictions
for each point and Adam atomizer and of
course we chose the best hyper parameter
for each of the methods to be fair for
the Gaussian processes we use the square
exponential covariance function you've
seen before and also this there was done
some other permits hyper parameter
optimization to get the right idea
torque noise so if you want to compare
something of course you might think okay
what kind of error functions what
metrics you want to look at and first of
all we have the mean squared error in
the
and for the for the mean and the
standard deviation then we looked at the
mean negative log likelihood so this is
the function that the deep ensemble
method is directly trying to minimize
and the mean callback liber divergence
because this is also often use used so
what were the results so especially for
the metrics of the mean squared error so
how could our mean actually is and
standard deviation as well as the mean
kullbackleibler divergence we see if
what was cool to see being a
mathematician of course that the
baseline the Gaussian process was much
better than the other ones but if you go
for a deep learning method then the deep
ensemble which was also computationally
quite intense turned out to be the best
for the interpolation experiments so you
might wonder how does it now look did we
achieve our goal I mean we wanted to
have interpolation and extrapolation so
just by looking with the ISO
interpolation looks good I mean these
were the numbers shown before but
extrapolation the Montecarlo drop out at
least what we wanted is as we move evade
uncertainty increases this is also with
the deep ensembles and with it with the
drop out ensembles and the quantile
regression but somehow in our example
they really all had problems in this
like narrow arm of the function because
here they definitely underestimate the
increase in uncertainty so this these
regions and what you can also see is all
the drop out methods you have this this
kind of cheat mean so this is due to
this that you have the drop out and also
the
uncertainty the confidence intervals
they look kind of strange in those kinds
of methods so for the deep ensembles
like only qualitatively looking it looks
quite well and quantile regression if
you can compare this to the Gaussian
process so this is actually what I would
have liked to see also for the for the
deep learning based models because here
you see directly okay we are moving away
from the ten and Gaussian process by its
definition goes back to its prior so you
end up being in a complete like
uninformed state you might say okay this
is kind of unfair because this is some a
priori knowledge that we've put in there
but in many use cases you have this
knowledge and then it's nice to see that
yeah that this does exactly what you
want it to do talking a little bit about
like how efficient this the whole thing
is how data efficient I mean as you we
have here the Y and X X is the number of
data points and one of the measures to
car L divergence and the the Gaussian
process needs only little data to be
quite good actually and then kind of
like levels out the deep learning based
models like quantile regression deep
ensembles the more data you give the
better it gets like typical for deep
learning methods what we found quite
interesting is that all the drop out
based methods they kind of improve up to
a certain point but then hit a barrier
and go on so we assume this is due to
the fact that there is this drop out I
mean it gets also some noise into the
prediction that might be unwanted and
then one would have maybe to play a
little bit more with the fact that maybe
in lower levels you want the different
drop out rate and in higher levels and
of course then it becomes really
problematic to optimize but yeah this is
something we found okay it's
not behaving so nicely there how about
hit was Scholastic noise so what happens
if the noise changes throughout the
function this is also something you
might have then Gaussian processes are
quite bad because I mean the the one of
the assumption is that it's almost get a
stick so if you if you yeah if you don't
adhere to this to this assumption then
it becomes quite bad in this case depos
wobble could still handle the situation
quite well how about non Gaussian noise
here we chose exponential noise there
was not that much of a difference
between the different methods so I would
actually would have expected that the
Gaussian process is much worse in this
case because it also even has a normal
distribution as one of its assumption
but in this example it worked quite well
another thing I just want to mention so
why did I give all this uncertainty
splits definitions about aleatory and
epistemic noise the cool thing about the
ensemble methods is that you can now do
a split like this you can like split up
the the dis averaging of the of the
different parameters of your normal
distribution into an elliot auric part
and into an epistemic part and this
gives you then confidence interval of
your Elliot or ik and your epidemic
noise this is really cool because for
instance we see here that in during the
in the interpolation the epistemic noise
is actually kind of zero the idea TOEIC
noise is it's blue so we might be happy
at that region in a practical use case
for instance but here it's just the
other way around here the epistemic
grows and this could tell us in some use
case okay please get more data for this
region to improve our uncertainty so
to sum the whole thing up if we just
maybe look at the column so my kind of
take away after this master thesis was
that if I have a small or medium sized
data set I would definitely and I can
make assumption that I got some
homoscedasticity normal distribution and
that it's not not changing then I would
definitely go for caution processes
because they are only really bad if you
have a lot of data and you also can get
this nice uncertainty split that I just
showed before if it really has to be big
data and if you have a lot of compute
power that you can paralyze then deep
ensemble stage work also really pretty
well but as I said their computation it
really intends the quantile regression
is a really really simple method so if
you have like no time and you don't have
as much compute resources and you don't
care about uncertainty split then you
could go for this method it's really
easy to implement and the drop out
methods they are mathematically really
interesting so I yeah such as you to to
read the papers because they even have a
nice link to the that this drop out this
multicolored drop out so this paper that
they have a nice link that you could
even think of this as a deep Gaussian
process so there is an interesting paper
but practically we found the results not
really convincing and the own methods
that like we came up doing the master
Theseus is also quite yeah it's also
quite quite nice it has done certain
displayed but in some cases yeah it's
kind of comparable to the Monte Carlo so
I want to conclude just the the last two
slides so our conclusion is that you can
do uncertainty quantification also with
deep learning maths based method
especially if you're looking for the
aleatory uncertainty they are not really
capable by estimate
epistemic uncertainty we saw this in a
simple one the example and I mean in
practice you're gonna have like
multi-dimensional spaces and if it
doesn't work in 1d it will not work in
in in higher dimensions so be careful
with this a caution process on the other
hand are really cool and I think maybe
in some cases you should rather use them
instead of using just some some deep
neural network and of course the
combined solution would be really great
because we're gonna need uncertainty
complication three things we haven't
really looked into but want to look into
our base neural networks so the case
when each weight in your neural networks
our distributions on their own then
there is fast Gaussian process as
approximation this is kind of a trick
how you can do Gaussian processes on on
big data so instead of like using each
data point you come up with a good set
of supporting points and this kind of
relieves you from the fact of inverting
a huge covariance matrix and then
there's also Gaussian process on top of
neural networks this is something we
also need to read up more so this is
something we would like to look into so
I hope you learned a little bit about
uncertainty quantification in AI thanks
for your attention and yeah I'm happy to
hear questions thank you for this nice
job probably we have time just for one
small questions and you can continue
discussion probably after so please
questions hi all right thanks for the
talk it might be confidential but for
what do you use it in practice or do you
use it for anything in practice some
some kind of uncertainty estimation for
your predictions yeah you in in cases
where you actually yeah in cases where
you do for instance the demand forecast
and then you
and off let's say you actually it will
be quite similar to the next talk but to
give a little like like like spree
spoiler if you do it demand and then you
actually don't care just about the
prediction what the demand will be
tomorrow right if you are the person
like needing to decide how many apples
or let's say sushi is needed the next
day in store right and someone would
give you just a regression would say
well confidence interval them you might
need like 50 to 70 apples and this is
the distribution so what would you do
with this now so you would actually need
to run some optimization on this so it
okay so to say it the other way around
if a normal neural network would just
tell you with a mean you need 70 apples
tomorrow this is not you would not order
70 apples because maybe it is like this
that if you have too many apples then
you have to throw them away but this
costs you less then if someone buys an
apples so you have an asymmetric like
cost function and if someone gives you
only a single point you cannot really
apply this cost function that it's for
you better to actually have a little bit
more apples than than less apples and if
you want to optimize this then you can
you need a distribution and this is then
the case when our customers ask us for
methods that give them whole
distributions and this is basically so a
lot of it's mostly about a demand
forecasting for yeah for retailers okay
so thank you let's thank the speaker
again
[Applause]
[Music]